Salut à vous de bon matin, une petit vidéo bonus !
On va parler de mentalisme et on va aussi parler de réflexion et de casse-tête !
Cet étrange objet composé de 4 parties est un casse-tête, duquel il faut réussir à enlever la boule.
Encore une phrase étrange sur ma chaîne YouTube, mais on va y revenir dans quelques secondes.
Je profite juste de cette vidéo pour vous dire que si vous êtes du côté de Rochefort-Du-Gard , d'Avignon, dans cette zone là,
je suis ce soir en spectacle à Rochefort-Du-Gard.
Ca se passe à 20H00, c'etist dans le cadre du festiv' du rire.
J'y jouerai une heure de mon nouveau spectacle, celui que je vais faire à l'Olympia.
Et petite cerise sur le gâteau, le festival est soutenu par la mairie, les places sont à 5€ et 10€.
Voilà. Vous avez le lien dans la description.
Et tant qu'on en est à faire un point, je joue mon nouveau spectacle à partir de septembre à l'Olympia,
ça part en tournée dans plus de quarante villes.
Vous avez les infos sur mon site Internet qui est dans la description.
Dès qu'une billetterie ouvre ses portes, je mets le lien sur le site.
Et on va attaquer ce fabuleux objet.
Qui me rend ouf, je le trouve extrêmement joli.
La manière dont est faite la boule est déjà très jolie.
Et la manière dont est fait le casse-tête et sa résolution est très joli.
Vous savez que tous les ans sur la chaîne YouTube, l'été j'aime bien faire un concept.
Alors cette année le concept est beaucoup plus simple que les autres années.
Je garde le principe de faire une vidéo tous les mercredis à 6H00 du matin.
Je ne change pas, parce que comme ça vous savez qu'une fois que le mercredi 6H est passé, il y a une nouvelle vidéo.
Et chaque semaine je vais résoudre un casse-tête.
Mais pas forcément des comme ça.
Je me suis aussi procuré des niveaux 10/10.
7/10
Des boîtes à ouverture secrète comme la Pandora Box.
Et donc je ne sais pas si je réussirai à ouvrir tout les casse-têtes.
Mais je pense que ça peut être sympa de faire ça ensemble.
Mais évidemment il n'y aura pas que des casse-tête.
Je vais alterner les vidéos de casse-têtes les mercredis avec une vidéo qui sortira je ne sais pas quand...
où je ferai soit des démonstrations de choses qu'il y a dans mon nouveau livre.
Le lien en description évidemment.
Très très bonne petite lecture d'été !
Soit des astuces de mentalisme; courtes, moyennes, longues...
Je n'en sais rien, cela dépendera des astuces.
Pour cette première vidéo, j'ai pris un casse-tête de difficulté 4/10, je crois...
En fait, sa particularité est très simple:
il ne faut pas voir la boule comme un ensemble, et ne pas voir l'entourage comme un ensemble.
Si on regarde bien la manière de le chercher,
on n'a qu'une action possible c'est de faire ça (tourner le contour) et de tourner la boule.
Donc, on sait déjà de base que ce ne sera pas la bonne solution.
Parce que le geste que l'on peut faire au départ sur les casse-têtes n'est souvent pas le bon.
J'ai commencé par lui, parce que c'est l'un des mes préférés et que celui-ci je l'ai depuis longtemps.
Donc forcément je l'ai déjà craqué !
Attention, petit spoiler alerte.
Là je vais le résoudre devant vous.
Donc si vous le voulez, je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Dans ce cas, n,e regardez pas tout de suite la suite.
Il faut l'imaginer encore une fois comme 4 parties différentes et non pas comme 2.
On est biaisé parce qu'on pense qu'il y en a 2, mais non il y en a vraiment 4.
Puisque la boule est en 2 pièces différentes.
Ce qui fait que si vous alignez comme ça,
la séparation des 2 blocs, ainsi que la déparation des 2 boules,
alors vous n'avez plus qu'à tourner un petit peu comme une vis,
et les deux parties se défont,
et forcément les quatre parties également
C'est à cause de ça que c'est un de mes casse-têtes préférés, parce que je trouve que la manière dont ils ont eu pour tailler la boule,
pour avoir cette idée, est complètement dingue.
Regardez, juste comme ça.
Je vais vous mettre une vidéo très courte sur Instagram aujourd'hui sur mon igtv
vous pouvez suivre mon Instagram en cliquant là,
ou dans la description.
De la résuolution de comment le défaire et le refaire.
Parce que le but d'un casse-tête c'est dans les deux sens.
Je vous mets ça dès aujourd'hui comme ça si vous voulez voir, vous allez voir sur Insta.
Pensez à liker cette vidéo.
Mettez un petit commentaire des casse-têtes que vous aimeriez que je résolve ou des astuces que je traite pour cet été.
Cette vidéo me permettait aussi de vous donner le programme des deux mois à venir.
J'espère que vous êtes déjà peut-être en vacances.
Et que sinon ça ne va pas tarder à arriver.
Pensez à vous abonner. A très bientôt !
Ciao !